I am Ricardo Hausmann and the director
of Center for International Development
at Harvard University I moderated a
panel on inclusive growth now when you
think about social and economic progress
they're having in history of thought two
approaches one approach says that the
history of society is the history of
class grow and progress is achieved when
one class it's the Alabama and changes
days what I think was the dominant
lesson from the panel island is that
instead of conflict that really the
source of progress is expansion in the
areas of human cooperation human
cooperation within organizations such as
companies that imply that many
individuals are working to it earlier in
an organization but in cooperation in
terms of government being able to
cooperate with civil society in the
private sector the private sector
structuring itself so that it can
cooperate between different firms and
with a social sector and the government
and the government learning how to how
to achieve a associations and
partnerships that allow the whole to
expand the areas of cooperation we saw
enormous areas for cooperation right now
the world economy is growing but it's
growing so fast that it's putting
pressure on the price of food and on the
price of energy so obviously policies
that can relax those constraints be the
technology institutions access to arable
land improved productivity is definitely
one critical area for people to be able
to produce more food so that eco
we can grow people can increase those
living standards and have more spying
accidents but we also saw the the
enormous inequality and dreams that are
in society it's not just inequality in
income but inequality and the things
that young people can bring about living
with their life and there you can see
enormous possibilities in the expansion
not just of education but of training
and entrepreneurship of the
possibilities to empower people with the
capacity to dream and the capacity to
imagine an organized so there are plenty
of things that are only going to happen
if we find the ways in which civil
society the private sector the
government can relate to each other with
sufficient legitimacy and credibility so
that they're really trusting each other
and finding avenues and opportunities
for progress